so i'm gonna go ahead and add a little
rice here without getting it in the oil
or starting a fire
i'm getting it all over the table but
it's all right it's gonna be amazing
just try to keep everything under half a
calorie or so
[Music]
hello my name is tyree and i'm a
bodybuilder here in los angeles
and today we're going to make an
omelette hey what's up everybody my name
is quan bailey i'm a personal trainer
if i was getting ready for like a
bodybuilding show like i am currently i
would eat
a ton of chicken and rice so this is
just a walk in the park
just a little smaller i'm usually good
in the kitchen uh i definitely have more
ingredients than this
um so i have pretty big hands so i feel
like this tiny cook is gonna pose quite
a challenge for me
and i'm supposed to plate it too okay
i don't know how to use this
oh oh it's almost the same size as the
bowl
how am i gonna cook the rice i'm gonna
have to boil some water aren't i
we're going to actually use the fork
to whip the egg you see that
oh yeah i'm getting it all over the
table but it's all right it's going to
be amazing
all right time to get this oven lit this
is a little different than i'm used to
there we go all right
put that on the burner it might be a
little too much we're gonna start
cutting the tomato with the butter knife
then we're gonna get this chicken going
get a little bit of olive oil
i really mean a little bit pretty simple
that should be enough
it's not working as i thought it would
okay the knife is not as sharp as i
thought it would be
but we're getting through it sometimes
when i'm cooking at home
i like to put the rice in the water
before it's boiled i'm gonna go ahead
and add a little
rice here without getting it in the oil
or starting a fire
all right so that's about as good as
we're getting with the tomato
i wouldn't say it's minced but it's
chopped a little bit i this will
probably be the smallest cut of chicken
i've ever made in my life so
hopefully this works all right let's get
this in here
it's gonna be a little submerged but it
should work all right we're getting
going then i'm gonna take
the broccoli break it into little pieces
mix it in with the tomato i love this
little piece of broccoli that i have no
idea what i'm gonna do with
i'm probably just gonna eat it like that
my favorite vegetables
are tomatoes mushrooms spinach i like
asparagus
body builders are boring we just eat the
same thing all the time next step i'm
gonna
dump the vegetables in the egg
just to mix the tomato and broccoli
we're still just waiting for this to uh
heat up over here let me just pull these
burners over a little bit
this is so interesting it's getting hot
we're getting there it looks like it's
gonna be pretty good i gotta just stop
spilling it all over the table but i'm
going to
light my candles so we can get this
going there we go it's starting to cook
there we go
add a little more rice wasn't smooth at
all
oh that's too much oil not sure what
this does is this a spoon
oh maybe i can that's what this is for
it's starting to cook the rice is
starting to get there
and let that oil heat up and we're gonna
lightly season the egg funny thing about
cooking with small utensils
is i feel like my hands are burning from
just trying to control everything
all tight i can't just be all rough like
i normally am
oh oh okay
okay wait guys this we almost got it let
me just
there we go oop
there we go all right my egg is cooking
i missed the stove kind of but
we're in there i think it's starting to
do something it might be edible soon
everyone you might be getting there
this is taking me back to my childhood
with my easy bake oven
i know y'all can see that color change
now that meat looks pretty good moment
of truth i'm gonna try it
it's done here we go look at this
omelette oh
crap it broke it's okay if your omelette
falls apart
just call it a scramble
all right first omelet is ready it's
well done you have all your vegetables
in there
actually it looks pretty good i hope you
guys can all appreciate these these
plating skills over here
these tiny utensils there we go
and that's how you do tiny cooking right
there all right my omelette is ready and
it's time to taste
it looks pretty good actually got the
good vegetables in there
season you know what let's just use all
the things see if i can uh make this
work
i feel like a giant i'm just trying to
use my little knife
i don't want anyone judging me off of
this omelette specifically but it's
pretty good
i'm gonna give up on that now
it tastes great i'm going to throw away
all manners going forward and we're
going to just
done how do you feel i feel accomplished
and hungry for some more actual food
[Music]